so first off here
after all these years how is this only
the first time you're voicing an
animated character was there ever a
point where you were offered an
opportunity like that and it just didn't
work for whatever reason i have three
words you tell me
you know i i
must say in in
[Music]
not in personal audition but i did
many audition tapes for major agencies
and never got one thing for years uh
one of the ways i accidentally backed
into the business even though i was
fascinated with the business that i've
been a cinematographer and director
filmmaker since i was 15 years old
um i was 18 i was walking down the
street and somebody stopped me excuse me
could i talk to you and said would you
be interested in being in a commercial
and i said like what would i have to do
and they said well all you got to do is
you know dress up like a young cowboy
and drive this truck
and i said
i wouldn't have to talk would i and i
said nope no talking
what's it pay 400 bucks oh
i'll take that job so that was with bbd
you know the largest company
in the united states that did that stuff
i did two dodge i did a gala wine
commercial
and i sort
suddenly i had a screen actors guild
card
and this meant i had to be on the other
side of the camera the lens side you
know
which just scared the water out of me
so i went on and and i
and i went to school i went i tried to
get rid of this feeling
and i almost got it 50 60 years later
i would say you have it by now
so jumping into your very first animated
role is there anything about being so
hyper focused on voice work that even
after all these years has you know let
you discover something new about your
craft that you might not have even
realized was there before well i got
invited to uh by a friend i got assigned
by a friend
to narrate a series eight episodes
and that was robert downey jr and his
wife susan the series became
a worldwide number one on uh on
streaming
for a month
and because of that pixar became aware
of me and suddenly you know like okay
yeah
that's what he does for a living
and
i'm pick of the week
the voice of the week
after all those years
and uh
in in going to work for pixar and in a
matter of fact with both jobs i sort of
didn't have any choice robert said this
is what you're doing make your deal with
warner's do it on your own but just show
up and do this then pixar said we can't
tell you anything about the role we
can't give you the lines we can't you
just have to show up but we're going to
train you on the spot
because it's all a secret
and so
i got there and heard about zerg and i
mean i knew of cern but i didn't really
know the parameters of what they were
going to do with them
because they've taken them to a whole
nother area you know that they have yeah
yeah including an area of
self-examination and questioning life
and
parallel
worlds and
all those things anyway i i learned it
in an empty room with nobody around the
director and the whole staff was on
screen
from san francisco 400 miles away and
i'm in the pixar room in the studio
there where nobody showed up it was like
in the middle of pandemic time
nobody was around not one car in the
parking lot except mine
so this is a
huge adventure in a way you know it's a
good adventure too oh yeah and look it's
gonna make uh
it's a
it's a great movie for everybody have
you seen it i have seen it i saw it last
night yeah it's not it's not just a toy
movie it's quite quite the adventure the
personal examination and also for me
who's obsessed with cats socks is now is
now life that's it yeah yeah yeah never
been so obsessed and i think it opens
for pixar a whole new uh
type of movie